This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When was the last time you stayed awake at night, unable to sleep, replaying something in your head that happened that day? Did you notice how your thoughts coil back on themselves, how you went in circles as the night wore on? All of us, even those who have been spared the pain of insomnia, have heard that voice. If you've messed up a presentation at work, or flubbed a test at school, or been rejected in love, you've heard those nagging, doubting thoughts, burrowing themselves deeper and deeper into the recesses of your brain.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你上一次夜不能寐、无法入睡，脑子里不断重播着那天发生的事情，是在什么时候？你有没有发现，你的思绪是如何盘根错节、在深夜漫长的时光里不断兜圈子的？我们所有人，甚至那些免于失眠痛苦的人，都听过那个声音。如果你在工作中搞砸了一次演讲，或者在学校的考试中考砸了，又或者在爱情中遭到拒绝，你一定听过那些唠叨、怀疑的声音，它们正越来越深地钻进你大脑的隐秘角落。
Ugh, how could I say something so stupid? Why did I say that? Because it's a mess. I'm always so lazy. It really should have worked out. I cannot believe you forgot to fill out that permission form. You forgot about parent-teacher conferences. What the hell?
呃，我怎么能说出这么愚蠢的话？我为什么要那样说？因为这简直是一团糟。我总是这么懒。这本该顺利解决的。我真不敢相信你竟然忘了填那张许可表。你竟然忘了家长会。搞什么鬼？
Two thirds. My back hurts. My body is just falling apart. Why does this inner voice seem to love to torment us? Wouldn't life be better if we could just make it stop? When that negative inner voice takes hold, that is all we can hear because it is consuming our attention. Today we try to understand the purpose of that nagging voice inside your head. How it works and what you can do to make it work for you.
三分之二。我背疼。我的身体简直要垮了。为什么这个内在的声音似乎特别喜欢折磨我们？如果我们能让它停下来，生活会不会更好？当那个负面的内在声音占据主导时，我们只能听到它，因为它吞噬了我们的注意力。今天我们试图理解你脑海中那个唠叨声音的目的。它是如何运作的，以及你能做些什么来让它为你所用。
This week on Hidden Brain. You might be an expert. You might be a novice. You could be a veteran or just starting out in your career. You've almost certainly heard that voice inside your head, questioning if you know enough, questioning if you know enough, questioning if you are enough. At the University of Michigan, psychologist Ethan Cross studies that voice, what it does, why it exists,
本周《隐藏的大脑》。你可能是个专家。你可能是个新手。你可能是一位老兵，或者刚刚开始你的职业生涯。你几乎肯定听到过你脑海里的那个声音，质疑你懂的东西够不够，质疑你懂的东西够不够，质疑你是不是足够好。在密歇根大学，心理学家伊森·克罗斯研究那个声音、它的作用、它为什么存在，
and how we can learn to befriend it. Ethan Cross, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me, Shankar. It's an absolute delight to be here. Ethan, I want to start by talking about a couple of incidents in your own life where you had to confront what you call the chatter of your own inner voice.
以及我们如何学会与它做朋友。伊森·克罗斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我，尚卡尔。很高兴能来到这里。伊森，我想从你生命中的几起事件开始谈起，在这些事件中，你不得不面对你所谓的自己内心的声音的“杂音”。
When you started college at the University of Pennsylvania, you came in as a very strong student with stellar grades from high school. Can you tell me how you fared academically in your first few months at Penn? I think the best word that I could use to describe my experience is it was a disaster academically my first semester I came in,
当你开始在宾夕法尼亚大学读大学时，你带着高中优异的成绩进入学校，是一个非常优秀的优等生。你能告诉我你在宾大头几个月的学业表现如何吗？我想我能用来形容我的经历的最好词汇是，我的第一学期在学业上简直是一场灾难，
I had graduated as valedictorian from my high school and thought I knew how to study. And it turned out I did not know how to study very well for college classes and ended up getting a sea of bad grades. And I also felt like I didn't exactly fit in for college classes and ended up getting a sea of bad grades. And I also felt like I didn't exactly fit in at Penn. I had come from a working class neighborhood in Brooklyn, and I was surrounded now by students
我从高中以毕业生代表的身份毕业，以为自己懂得如何学习。事实证明，我其实并不太懂得如何应对大学课程的学习，结果得了一连串的烂成绩。我也觉得自己好像并不是特别融入宾大的大学课程，结果得了一连串的烂成绩。我也觉得自己好像并不是特别融入宾大。我来自布鲁克林的一个工人阶级社区，而现在我周围都是学生，
from more privileged backgrounds that I had come from, and they talked different, they dressed different. So all of those thoughts about whether I fit in, whether I belong, that became a distraction. And that weighed on me, that there was a mental burden that exerted, which was unpleasant and was something I had to figure out how to address. I wanna fast forward a couple of decades
他们有着比我更优越的背景，他们说话不同，穿着也不同。因此，所有关于我是否合群、是否属于这里的想法，都变成了一种干扰。这让我压力山大，它带来了一种心理负担，这种负担既令人不快，也是我必须想办法解决的问题。我想把时间快进几十年，
to another moment in your life when the voice inside your head was deafening. You'd become a successful academic, you were married, you had a growing family, and one day you were playing with your young daughter, getting her ready for her nap. Can you paint me a detailed picture of what you were doing and what happened next, Ethan?
来到你生命中的另一个时刻，那时你脑海中的声音震耳欲聋。你已经成为了一名成功的学者，你结了婚，有一个不断扩大的家庭，有一天你正在和年幼的女儿玩耍，为她午睡做准备。伊森，你能为我描绘一幅详细的画面，说说你当时在做什么，接下来又发生了什么吗？
This is a painful experience, even when I reflect back on it now. When my youngest daughter was less than one at the time or right around that age, we would have this ritual of sorts that we would engage in where before her nap, I'd read to her, I'd play a little bit, change her diaper, and then I would like launch her off of the changing table,
这是一段痛苦的经历，即使现在回想起来也是如此。当时我的小女儿还不到一岁，或者差不多那个年纪，我们有一种类似仪式的互动，在她午睡前，我会给她读读书，玩一会儿，给她换尿布，然后我会把她从尿布台上“发射”出去，
swirl her up and down like a spaceship in the sky, and then flip her on her back and very quickly kind of put her down in the crib and she would love it, always smiles and she always expected it. So it was something we did every single time. And this one episode, I started going through the procedure.
像天空中的宇宙飞行器一样把她上下旋转，然后把她翻过去，非常快地把她放进婴儿床里，她会非常喜欢，总是面带微笑，而且她总是期待着这个动作。所以这是我们每次都会做的事情。而在这次事件中，我开始走这套程序。
She knew exactly what was coming. She was loving it. And the only problem is when I went to land her, so to speak, in the crib, she started screaming. And when I say screaming, I mean, I'm talking about ear shattering screams were coming out of her mouth. And she started grabbing, reaching for her arm.
她清楚地知道接下来要发生什么。她很喜欢。唯一的问题是，当我把她“着陆”在婴儿床里（可以这么说）时，她开始尖叫。当我说尖叫时，我是指，我指的是她嘴里发出了震耳欲聋的尖叫声。她开始抓挠，伸手去抓她的胳膊。
And so I immediately called my wife, told her what happened. She then started to come home from work. And I'm then just, I'm sitting on the rocking chair with my daughter screaming, looking at me. And I'm thinking, oh my God, what did I do? I started, you know, simulating in my mind the worst case scenarios.
所以我立刻给我的妻子打了电话，告诉她发生了什么。她随后开始从工作的地方赶回家。然后我就坐在摇椅上，女儿在一旁尖叫着看着我。我在想，天哪，我都做了些什么？我开始，你知道的，在脑海中模拟最坏的情况。
You know, have I, have I permanently injured her? Are we going to be, is she going to need surgery? Oh my God, what, what does surgery like when a kid is this young? So I started catastrophizing as though that weren't sufficient for working me up. Then I went in a different direction with the catastrophization.
你知道的，我有没有，我有没有彻底弄伤她？我们是不是，她需不需要做手术？天哪，当孩子这么小时，手术是怎么样的？所以我开始将事情灾难化，就好像这还不足以让我心烦意乱一样。接着，我朝着灾难化的另一个方向想去。
I started thinking, what is the doctor gonna think when I bring my daughter in? Are they gonna think I might've deliberately hurt her? And that made me feel terrible. And when you couple that with the pain I felt when just looking at my child who was screaming in pain was a terribly chatter-provoking episode in my life and not a particularly pleasant episode to relive.
我开始想，当我把女儿带去医院时，医生会怎么想？他们会以为我是故意伤害她的吗？这让我感觉糟糕透顶。当你把这些与看着因痛苦而尖叫的孩子时感受到的心痛结合在一起时，这是我生活中一段极易引发杂音的插曲，而且并不是一段特别令人愉快的回忆。
Ethan would later discover his daughter had dislocated her elbow. But in that moment, the uncertainty of not knowing what had happened allowed his chatter to spin out of control. Oh, absolutely. I mean, we know that uncertainty can fuel chatter because we don't know what's going to happen. And, you know, our mind is incredibly adept at simulating
伊森后来发现女儿的肘关节脱臼了。但在那一刻，不知道发生了什么的不确定性，让他的杂音彻底失控了。哦，绝对是的。我的意思是，我们知道不确定性会助长杂音，因为我们不知道会发生什么。而且，你知道的，我们的头脑极其擅长模拟，
all sorts of possibilities and in that moment my mind was it was firing on all cylinders and that certainly contributed to that negative state I was experiencing. And I feel that this is as close to a universal experience as there is I think almost everyone experiences this. One of the more dramatic examples of this phenomenon that took place in public involves a baseball pitcher, Rick Ankeel. And for listeners who don't know much about baseball, can you tell me a bit about Rick Ankeel and describe step by step
各种各样的可能性，在那一时刻，我的大脑全速运转，这无疑加剧了我当时经历的负面状态。我觉得这几乎是一种普遍的体验，我认为几乎所有人都会经历这一点。这种现象在公众面前的一个更具戏剧性的例子涉及一名棒球投手——里克·安基尔。对于不太了解棒球的听众，你能跟我们讲讲里克·安基尔，并一步步描述一下，
what happened on October 3rd, 2000? Sure. So Rick Ankeel was a new pitcher in the major leagues. And when he arrived on the St. Louis Cardinals, he was touted as the next greatest thing. Not just that year, but he had the potential to be according to the pundits, one of the greatest pitchers of all time. And throughout his first year in the league,
2000年10月3日那天发生了什么吗？当然。所以里克·安基尔是美国职业棒球大联盟的一名新星投手。当他来到圣路易斯红雀队时，他被吹捧为下一个伟大的传奇。不仅在那一年，根据专家的预测，他甚至有潜力成为有史以来最伟大的投手之一。在他联盟的第一年里，
that's exactly how he performed. He was lights out and ace pitcher. His team ended up getting to the playoffs and during one of the playoff games he took the mound and a few few batters into the game, he did something that was very uncommon for him. One on, one out, and a wild pitch. The ball hit the dirt at the batter's feet and shot past the catcher. The runner on first ambled over to second base. This was not the sort of thing fans expected from Rick Ankeel.
他的表现也确实如此。他势不可挡，是一名王牌投手。他的球队最终打进了季后赛，在其中一场季后赛中，他走上了投手丘，在投了几名打者之后，他做了一件对他来说很不寻常的事。一垒有人，一人出局，投出一个暴投。球落在了打者脚前的泥土里，从捕手身旁飞过。一垒上的跑者慢悠悠地晃到了二垒。这可不是球迷们对里克·安基尔的期望。
It was uncommon for him because he had such incredible control over where he placed the ball and after he throws this wild pitch he pauses and he says to himself, huh, I just threw a wild pitch. He shrugged it off and then he winds up to throw another pitch and this one's even more wild than the one that came before it. Another wild pitch over the head of Fernandez and back to the backstop. And now he's starting to wonder what is going on. He winds up for another pitch.
这对他来说很不寻常，因为他对球的落点有着难以置信的控制力，在他投出这个暴投后，他停顿了一下，对自己说：“哈，我刚刚投了一个暴投。”他耸耸肩，然后准备投出下一球，而这一球比之前的那个还要离谱。又是一个暴投，飞过费尔南德斯的头顶，直奔挡网而去。现在他开始纳闷到底是怎么回事了。他摆好姿势准备投下一球。
Wow. To the screen again, it hits off the backstop and right back to him. And this one is even more wild than the last. It sails over the the catcher and the umpire and on and on he goes through this inning it's incredibly painful to watch his implosion on the mound. And another wild one and Maddux will score. It's ball four to Galarraga. A pitcher who previously was able to hit targets with pinpoint precision and he's just walking batters across the bases and ultimately has to be taken out of the game never regains
哇。又朝着挡网飞去，撞在挡网上又反弹回了他手里。这一球比上一球还要离谱。它飞越了捕手和裁判的头顶，就这样一球接一球，看着他在投手丘上彻底崩溃，过程简直痛苦万分。又是一个暴投，马杜克斯将得分。加拉拉加四坏球保送。一个以前能够以极高的精准度命中目标的投手，现在却把打者一个个保送上垒，最终不得不被换下场，再也没有恢复
his form when describing what he underwent on the field that day and during subsequent outings in which he tried to regain his control, he talks about this monster that was born inside him and the monster is a name that he gives to his chatter. I wake up in the middle of the night, you know, having the nightmare that I couldn't throw a strike. I'm soaked in sweat and it's like this thing won't even leave me alone during my sleep. Every time he would wind up to throw a pitch, he would start thinking about, is he squeezing the ball too tight or is it too loose?
过状态。在描述他在那天球场上的遭遇以及后来试图恢复控制力的几次比赛时，他谈到了一个在他体内诞生的“怪物”，“怪物”是他对脑海中杂音的称呼。我在半夜醒来，做着自己无法投出好球的噩梦。我浑身大汗淋漓，感觉这个东西甚至连我睡觉时都不肯放过我。每次他准备投球时，他就会开始琢磨，自己是不是把球攥得太紧了，还是太松了？
Is he distributing his weight appropriately? And ultimately, this monster, his chatter, ended up sinking his career. You say that the voice that he heard that day, this voice that he called the monster, was louder than the 52,000 fans who were in the stands watching. I mean, that's an extraordinary statement, Ethan. I think it's also a statement that rings true for many people. There's some wonderful research which shows that
他体重的分配是否合适？最终，这个怪物——他的杂音，彻底葬送了他的职业生涯。你说他那天听到的声音，这个被他称为“怪物的声音”，比看台上观看比赛的52,000名球迷的呐喊声还要大。我的意思是，这是一个非同寻常的说法，伊森。我认为这也是一个能引起许多人共鸣的说法。有一些很棒的研究表明，
often what predicts how we feel at any given moment in time is not, is not what we're actually doing, but it's the thoughts streaming through our head. So you can be on a carnival ride with your kids that should be enormously fun, but you're worried about how the last conversation went with a guest, where things were a little choppy, and you're not having fun. This speaks to, I think, exactly what Anne Keele
通常决定我们在任何特定时刻感受如何的，不是我们实际在做什么，而是在我们脑海中流淌的思绪。所以你可能正和孩子们在游乐园里坐着嘉年华游乐设施，这本该是非常快乐的，但你却在担心刚才和一个客人的谈话进展得怎么样，当时情况有点僵，于是你一点也不觉得快乐。我认为，这正好说明了安基尔在那个时刻所经历的一切，
experienced in that moment, and what so many of us experience at times, which is when that chatter starts brewing, when that negative inner voice takes hold, that is all we can hear because it is consuming our attention. That negative inner voice is often lying in wait, ready to chime in. It refuses to let mistakes go and reminds us of them at the worst possible moment. When we come back, the many different drivers of this chatter and reminds us of them at the worst possible moment. When we come back, the many different drivers of this chatter and the psychological techniques we can use to master the voices inside our heads. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
也是我们许多人在某些时刻所经历的，那就是当杂音开始酝酿，当那个负面的内心声音占据主导时，我们只能听到它，因为它吞噬了我们的注意力。那个负面的内心声音往往潜伏在暗处，随时准备插话。它拒绝让错误过去，并在最糟糕的时刻提醒我们。当我们回来时，我们将探讨导致这种杂音的诸多不同驱动因素，以及我们可以用来掌控内心声音的心理学技术。你在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Psychologist Ethan Cross studies the phenomenon of self-talk and chatter, the voices we all hear incessantly inside our heads. We've seen how chatter can take the form of a merciless tormentor. Once baseball star Rick Ankeel made one mistake, We've seen how chatter can take the form of a merciless tormentor. Once baseball star Rick Ankeel made one mistake, his inability to set that mistake aside produced the next mistake and the next and the next. When Ethan accidentally hurt his young daughter, he found it really hard to forgive himself. The harsh and unforgiving judge is a common role that is played by our inner voice.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家伊森·克罗斯研究了自言自语和杂音的现象，也就是我们所有人不断在脑海中听到的声音。我们已经看到杂音如何呈现出一个无情折磨者的形态。棒球明星里克·安基尔犯了一个错误之后……我们已经看到杂音如何呈现出一个无情折磨者的形态。棒球明星里克·安基尔犯了一个错误之后，他无法放下这个错误，从而导致了下一个错误，接着是下一个，再下一个。当伊森不小心伤害了他年幼的女儿时，他发现自己真的很难原谅自己。严厉且不依不饶的法官，正是我们内心声音经常扮演的角色。
But the more Ethan studied the phenomenon of chatter, the more he realized it comes in many guises. Ethan, some years ago you made an appearance on television that set off a firestorm of chatter inside your head. Now this was a different kind of chatter. Start by telling me about the TV appearance and what happened afterwards. This was early in my career and my colleagues
但伊森对杂音现象研究得越多，他就越意识到它有着许多不同的伪装。伊森，几年前你在电视上露面，在你的脑海中引发了一场杂音的风暴。现在，这是一种不同类型的杂音。请先跟我讲讲那次电视亮相以及之后发生了什么。那是我职业生涯的早期，我和同事们
and I published a study that we were really excited about. It dealt with the idea that when we're rejected by someone else in a romantic relationship, people may actually be referring to physical sensations in their body when they experience social pain. And this was a study we were really excited about. We didn't particularly expect it to get a lot of attention, but many people came calling. And one minute I'm lecturing in introductory social psychology about the psychology of
发表了一项让我们非常兴奋的研究。它探讨了这样一个观点：当我们被恋爱关系中的某个人拒绝时，人们在经历社会痛苦时，实际上可能是在指代他们身体中的生理感觉。这是一项让我们非常兴奋的研究。我们并没有特别指望它会受到太多的关注，但许多人找上门来。前一分钟我还在讲授入门社会心理学中关于爱情心理学的课程，
love. And the next minute I'm in a studio across campus doing an interview for the CBS Evening News. So when we're alone, we experience physical pain, and that's a cue to say it's time to get things back on track. And that's what... Fast forward about a week after this interview aired, I walk into work and I notice a letter that's hand addressed to me. And I proceeded to open the envelope and that's where I saw a really chilling, disturbing note
后一分钟我就在校园另一头的演播室里接受CBS《晚间新闻》的采访。所以当我们独处时，我们会经历身体上的痛楚，这是一个信号，告诉我们是时候让事情回到正轨了。这就是……把时间快进到这次采访播出一周左右后，我走进办公室，注意到一封手写收件人地址的信。我接着打开了信封，正是在那里，我看到了一张写给我的非常令人心寒、不安的便条，
had been written to me. All sorts of racial slurs, threats, ugly drawings of me. I immediately broke out into a sweat. And the first thing I remember, the first thing I did was I showed it to my assistant just to get a second set of eyes on this to make sure I wasn't jumping to an extreme. And I looked at her face and I remember her face went white. And the first thing she said to me is,
上面写满了各种种族的侮辱、威胁以及对我的丑陋涂鸦。我顿时吓出一身冷汗。我记得我做的第一件事，我做的第一件事就是把它拿给我的助手看，只是想找第二双眼睛来看看这封信，确保我没有小题大做。我看着她的脸，我记得她的脸刷地一下变白了。她对我说出的第一句话是：
you need to tell someone about this. A couple of hours later, after talking to folks in the department and at the university, I ended up at the police station, show them the letter, ask them what to do. So their advice to me was to keep an eye out for people who look suspicious for the next few days
你得把这件事告诉别人。几个小时后，在和系里以及大学里的人谈过之后，我最终去了警察局，把信给他们看，问他们该怎么办。所以他们给我的建议是，在接下来的几天里留意那些看起来可疑的人，
and make sure to drive home a different way from work each day, which was kind of comical because at the time I lived just a few blocks from campus. And this activated some chatter, for the next few days I couldn't sleep. I was pacing my house. I had my baseball bat resting on my shoulder. I was in protector mode.
并确保每天开车回家时走不同的路线，这其实挺搞笑的，因为当时我住的地方离校园只有几个街区。这激活了一些杂音，在接下来的几天里我无法入睡。我在屋里踱来踱去。我把棒球棒搭在肩膀上。我进入了防御模式。
I was constantly thinking to myself, what have I done? Why did I do this interview? My first daughter had just been born. I've put her at risk. I put my wife at risk. It was really a scary moment in life, and it was an all consuming one. And when your chatter is consuming your attention for a long period of time, that makes it really
我不断地对自己说，我都做了些什么？我为什么要接受这个采访？我的大女儿刚刚出生。我把她置于危险之中。我把我的妻子置于危险之中。那真的是我生命中可怕的一个时刻，也是一个吞噬我一切的时刻。当你的杂音长时间吞噬你的注意力时，这会让你很难在生活中去做其他重要的事情，比如你的工作、指导你的学生、写论文，甚至是对你的伴侣和孩子做个好伴侣、好父母，对吧？因为他们试图跟我说话，而我却在考虑这个潜在的威胁。这就是那封信和杂音，我是这样称呼那段插曲的。伊森脑海中的杂音让他一次又一次地回想起那封信。他试图解读关于寄信之人的线索。他试图理解他们的意图。
hard for you to do other things in your life that matter like your work, like advising your students, writing papers, or even being a good partner and parent to your partner and kids, right? Because they're trying to talk to me and I'm thinking about this potential threat. So that was the letter in the chatter as I refer to that episode. The chatter inside Ethan's mind brought him back to the letter over and over again. He was trying to decipher clues about the person who sent it. He was trying to understand their intentions.
信其实是附近一个小镇寄来的，这也放大了人们对潜在威胁的感知。但这封信没有任何理由让这个人做出他所做出的那些指控，没有任何理由让他把我画成那样，也没有任何理由说出他所说的话，但这并不会让它在当时显得不那么具有威胁性。这就是杂音对我们所做的事情，因为它让我们聚焦于我们所关心的事物，
It was actually from a nearby town, which also magnified the significance of the perceived threat. But there was no reason why this person was making the accusations that they were making. There was no reason why they drew the pictures of me that they did and why they said the things they did, but that didn't make it in that moment any less threatening. And that's what chatter does to us because it zooms us in on the things we're concerned about,
无论是我们是否融入集体、我们的成绩如何、我们是否被拒绝，还是是否有人要来杀我们，对吧？你如此狭隘地聚焦于手头的问题，以至于你失去了看清大局的能力。因此，与这种“充满恐惧的预言家”的想法相关的另一种形式的杂音，就是反刍思维的问题。我想我们很多人都深受其害。你知道的，我们被一件小事困扰，然后我们不断地、不断地、不断地拉扯着那个
whether it be whether we belong, whether we're making grades, whether we've been rejected, or whether someone's coming to kill us, right? You're zoomed in so narrowly on the problem at hand, you lose the ability to see that bigger picture. So another form of chatter that's related to this idea of the fearful prognosticator is the problem of rumination. And I think many of us are affected by this. You know, we're bothered by something small and then we pull and pull and pull on that
线团，直到（你知道的）非常小的土丘变成了巨大的高山。这方面的一个绝佳例子来自电视剧《宋飞正传》。角色伊莲正坐在一辆拥挤的地铁列车上，开心地想着她即将参加的一场婚礼。我很期待这个。我喜欢婚礼。也许我会遇到某个人。也许不会。
ball of thread until, you know, very small molehills become very big mountains. A great example of this comes from the TV show Seinfeld. The character Elaine is on a crowded subway train, happily thinking about an upcoming wedding she's about to attend. I'm really looking forward to this. I love weddings. Maybe I'll meet somebody. Maybe not.
天哪，我们停下来了？哦，天哪。我们停下来了？哦，太棒了。这正是我需要的，正是我需要的。好了，放轻松。我确信没什么大不了的。可能是轨道上有老鼠。他们为了老鼠停下来了。
Oh man, we're stopping? Oh, man. We're stopping? Oh, this is great. This is what I need, just what I need. Okay, take it easy. I'm sure it's nothing. Probably rats on the track. They're stopping for rats.
天哪，太挤了。怎么会有这么多人？如果我错过婚礼怎么办？我有戒指。他们会怎么办？没有戒指你不能结婚。哦，天哪。我错过婚礼了？我有戒指，他们会怎么办？没有戒指你不能结婚。我喘不过气来。我觉得快晕倒了。
God, it's so crowded. How could there be so many people? What if I missed the wedding? I got the ring. What'd they do? You can't get married without a ring. Oh, God. I missed the wedding? I got the ring, what'd they do? You can't get married without a ring. I can't breathe. I feel faint.
好吧，放轻松。列车很快就会开动的。想想集中营里的人，他们经历了什么。还有人质。如果你是人质你会怎么做？想想这个。这根本不算什么。
Okay, take it easy. It'll start moving soon. Think about people in concentration camps, what they went through. And the hostages. What would you do if you were a hostage? Think about that. This is nothing.
不，这不是什么都没有，这是有东西的。这是一场噩梦。救命。我腿上那个是什么？所以，显然，伊森，这是一部喜剧，但我喜欢这里的编剧从最小的烦恼开始，然后20秒后，伊莲就把自己被困在火车上，
No, it's not nothing, it's something. It's a nightmare. Help me. What's that on my leg? So, obviously, Ethan, this is comedy, but I love how the writers here start with the smallest of inconveniences, and then 20 seconds later, Elaine's comparing herself being stuck on a train
和身处集中营进行了对比。是的，人类大脑把小事化大、把事情灾难化的能力确实非常惊人。你知道，我非常喜欢这样一项研究。那是英国人类学家安德鲁·欧文（Andrew Irving）做的一项研究。几年前，他基本上走到纽约市的街道上，给路人一个麦克风，并要求他们把在任何特定时刻流经脑海的思绪流表达出来。你在那些外化的内心独白中看到的，非常类似于你在那个片段中听到伊莲，
to being in a concentration camp. Yeah, the mind's ability to make mountains out of molehills and to catastrophize is truly remarkable. You know, there's this one study that I really love. It was a study done by the British anthropologist Andrew Irving. He basically went up to New Yorkers on city streets several years ago and gave them a microphone and just asked them to City Streets several years ago and gave them a microphone and just asked them to verbalize the stream of thoughts that were flowing through their mind at any given moment in time. And what you see in those externalized inner monologues is something very similar to what you hear Elaine
经历的情景。我认为非常有趣的一点是，我们的内心声音具有非线性特征。伊莲在那个片段中经历着这些。我认为非常有趣的一点是，我们的内心声音具有非线性特征。我们的思绪像弹珠机一样到处乱撞。在那个片段中，伊莲不仅在想婚礼，然后她想到了集中营，接着又回到了地铁的环境。
going through in that clip. One thing that I think is so interesting is there's a non-linearity to our inner voice. Elaine going through in that clip. One thing that I think is so interesting is there's a non-linearity to our inner voice. We pinball back and forth all over the place. In that clip, Elaine's not just thinking about the wedding, but then she's going to the concentration camp and then she's going back to the subway conditions.
我们的思绪在非常迅速地前后跳跃。这些外化的内心独白还有一个非常值得注意的特征，那就是它们通常涉及负面内容，虽然不总是这样，但这构成了流淌在人们脑海中的大部分思想。我只是觉得这很了不起：我们在从一件负面事情转向另一件负面事情、并陷入那些情绪深渊的能力上，是多么的得心应手。
We're moving back and forth very rapidly. And the other feature of these externalizing or monologues that was so noteworthy is they often dealt with negative content, not always, but that was the majority of the kinds of thoughts that were streaming through people's heads. And I just find that remarkable at how facile we are in our ability to go from one negative thing to another and down
所以，反刍思维的另一个标志是，我认为我们会觉得自己在某个问题上取得了进展。就像我们在思考某件事，然后我们想，好吧，如果我们思考这个问题，我们现在就可以取得进展并解决问题。然后正如你所说，片刻之后，我们的思绪就像弹珠一样在17个不同的事情之间乱撞，然后我们没有意识到，但我们其实在原地打转。
those rabbit holes. So another hallmark of rumination is that I think we feel as if we're making progress on some problem. Like we're thinking about something and we think, okay, if we think about this problem, we can now make progress and solve the problem. And then as you say, moments later, we're pinballing off 17 different things, and then we don't realize it, but we are walking in circles.
我们就像那些在森林里迷路、在原地打转的人。你能谈谈这个吗？反刍思维的标志之一是它具有某种循环性，我们会一遍又一遍地回到相同的站点，却没有意识到我们在兜圈子？你知道的，杂音是我用来……我们一遍又一遍地回到相同的站点，却没有意识到我们在兜圈子。
We're like the people who are lost in a forest who are walking in circles. Can you talk about that, that one of the hallmarks of rumination is it has sort of this circularity to it, that we come back to the same stops over and over again, but we don't realize we're going in circles? You know, chatter is a term I use We come back to the same stops over and over again, but we don't realize we're going in circles.
你知道的，杂音是我用来形容陷入消极思维循环、这种固执的循环性的一个术语。反刍往往是关于对过去的沉溺。担忧更多是关于未来或现在发生的事情。但这两个不同状态的共同主题是这种消极的循环性，
You know, chatter is a term I use to refer to getting stuck in a negative thought loop, this perseverative circularity. Rumination tends to be about dwelling on the past. Worry is more about what's happening in the future or the present. But the common theme across both of those different states is this negative circularity,
这种固执的消极认知。这被认为是心理学家所称的“跨诊断风险因素”，它会导致许多不同形式的精神疾病，从各种形式的抑郁和焦虑，到其他类型的消极状态。例如，过度好斗且容易被激怒的人。
this perseverative negative cognition. And it is thought to be what psychologists call a transdiagnostic risk factor for many different forms of mental illness, ranging from various forms of depression and anxiety to other kinds of negative states. For example, people who are overly aggressive and easily set off.
许多这些情况的共同主题是，人们在一桩不当行为、冤屈或担忧上没完没了地唠叨、反复琢磨。所以我们已经看到内心声音如何呈现出严苛的法官或事后诸葛亮的形态。不久前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中邀请了凯文·科克利，他研究“冒名顶替现象”，即自我怀疑的现象，某种程度上这也与杂音的故事有关，即那些实际上非常擅长做某些事情的人，
The common theme across many of those conditions is that people are harping on some misdeed or grievance or concern over and over and over again. So we've seen how the inner voice can take the form of the, you know, the harsh judge or the second-guesser. Some time ago we featured Kevin Coakley on Hidden Brain and he studies the imposter phenomenon, the phenomenon of self-doubt, and in some ways that's also connected to the story of chatter, the ways in which people who are actually very good at doing some things
有时会开始对自己产生怀疑。你讲了罗杰斯先生的故事。在电视上，他给人的印象是泰然自若、充满自信，但在幕后，情况却完全是另一回事？是的，几年前《纽约时报》发表了一篇非常棒的关于杂音的文献。弗雷德·罗杰斯曾从他的节目中休假了一段时间。
can sometimes start to second guess themselves. You tell the story of Mr. Rogers. On TV, he came across as serenely self-confident, but behind the scenes, it was another picture altogether? Yeah, there's this wonderful chatter artifact of sorts that the New York Times published several years ago. Fred Rogers had gone on a kind of sabbatical for a while from his show.
当他回归时，他充满了自我怀疑，担心自己是否能够达到休假前同样的表现水平。在这封写给自己的信中，他非常、非常坦诚地表达了这种脆弱感。他写道：“我是自欺欺人吗？觉得自己还能再写出剧本？我很纳闷，为什么我就是不信任自己？过了这么多年，情况还是和以前一样糟。我想每个创意艺术家在努力创作时都会经历这种地狱般的折磨。好吧，时间到了，现在我必须去做了。动手吧，弗雷德。动手吧。”所以这对我来说真的很了不起。首先，我的意思是，我们在谈论罗杰斯先生，
And when he came back, he was filled with self doubt about whether he'd be able to perform at the same level that he did prior to taking his break. And in this letter that he writes to himself, he very, very candidly expresses that vulnerability. He writes, am I kidding myself that I'm able to write a script again? I wonder, why don't I trust myself? After all these years, it is just as bad as ever. I wonder if every creative artist goes through the tortures of the damn trying to create. Oh well, the hour cometh and now is when I've got to do it. Get to it, Fred. Get to it. So this is really remarkable to me. First of all, I mean, we're talking about Mr. Rogers,
你知道的，罗杰斯先生和无数其他孩子以及可能成年人一样，在我的成长过程中帮助我学会了如何管理自己的情绪。然而在这里我们看到他承认自己有时也在与自我怀疑作斗争。我认为这是一个非常重要的信息，可以传达给人们，因为它确实在告诉人们：嘿，如果你曾经经历过杂音，
you know, Mr. Rogers helped teach me how to manage my emotions growing up as he did countless other kids and probably adults too. And yet here we see him admitting to struggling with his own self-doubt at times. Which I think is such an important message to convey to folks because it really says to people, hey, if you've ever experienced chatter,
如果你曾经经历过自我怀疑，欢迎来到人类的境况，我们所有人有时都会经历。还有一个最后形式的消极杂音值得讨论。有时我们脑海中的声音呈现出的形态，不是愤怒的法官或充满恐惧的预言家，而是一个失望的父母或老师。不久前，《隐藏的大脑》听众何塞·贝拉斯克斯给我们分享了这个故事。我背叛了我最亲近的家庭成员之一的信任，
if you've ever experienced self-doubt, welcome to the human condition we all do at times. There is one final form of negative chatter worth discussing. Sometimes the voice inside our heads takes the form not of an angry judge or a fearful warrior, but a disappointed parent or teacher. Some time ago, hidden brain listener Jose Velasquez shared this story with us. I betrayed the trust of one of my closest family members
给他们留下了一场财务灾难，他们不得不完全靠自己去解决，这花去了他们差不多五年的时间才修复好。没有一天我不在想着这件事并为此痛恨自己。尽管那个被我背叛的人已经原谅了我，也明确地说过原谅了我，但我看不出自己怎么可能原谅自己。它每天都在折磨着我。所以，伊森，他说的“我看不出自己怎么能原谅自己”这句话让我触动很深。我想知道你是否能花点时间谈谈以“羞耻”角色出现的杂音？
members and left them with a financial disaster that they had to resolve entirely on their own and it took them the better half of five years to fix it. And there doesn't pass a single day where I don't think about it and hate myself for it. And even though the person I betrayed has forgiven me, has said so explicitly, I don't see how I'll ever forgive myself. It just haunts me every single day. So Ethan, I'm struck by the line where he says, I don't see how I can ever forgive myself. I'm wondering if you can talk for a moment about the chatter that comes in the role of shame.
杂音指的是陷入这些消极的思维循环中。这种消极情绪的内容可能会有所不同。在某些情况下，它可能充满引发焦虑的想法，但在其他情况下，正如你在这里所指出的，它也可能充满引发羞耻的想法。两者感觉都很糟糕，但方式非常不同。但在我与人们交谈以及对此课题进行研究的经验中，变得异常清晰的一点是，这种杂音体验对人们来说是多么的规范和普遍。我们的内心声音可以采取许多形式。它们会给我们带来巨大的痛苦。它们会在我们的关系中引起
Chatter refers to getting stuck in those negative thought loops. The content of that negativity can vary. In some cases, it could be filled with anxiety provoking thoughts, but in other cases as you're referring to here it could be filled with shame provoking thoughts as well. Both feel awful but in very different ways, but in my experiences talking to people and doing research on this topic what has become crystal clear is just how normative this experience of chatter is for people. Our inner voices can take many forms. They can cause us enormous anguish. They can cause
摩擦、损害我们的表现、使我们失去平衡。这足以让任何人渴望获得一丝平静与安宁。神经科学家吉尔·博尔特·泰勒正是遭遇了这种情况。1996年，她中风了，这让她脑海中那个折磨者的声音陷入了沉寂。她在TED演讲中描述了这种转变是怎样的。我脑海中的杂音完全消失了。就像有人拿了一个遥控器按下了静音键。一片死寂。
friction in our relationships, impair our performance, destabilize us. It's enough to make anyone wish for a little peace and quiet. That's exactly what happened to the neuroscientist, Jill Bolte Taylor. In 1996, she suffered a stroke that silenced the voice of her inner tormentor. She described what that change was like in a TED Talk. My brain chatter went totally silent. Just like someone took a remote control and pushed the mute button. Total silence.
起初，我惊恐地发现自己身处一个寂静的大脑中。我亲切地将这个空间称为“乌托邦”。但那里很美丽。想象一下，丢掉37年的情感包袱会是什么感觉。哦，我感到了极乐。当我们回来时，吉尔·博尔特·泰勒发现了一件事。那个她曾如此高兴摆脱的、唠叨烦人的声音，她开始想念它了。你在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
And at first I was shocked to find myself inside of a silent mind. And I affectionately refer to this space as La La Land. But it was beautiful there. Imagine what it would be like to lose 37 years of emotional baggage. Oh, I felt euphoria. When we come back, Jill Bolte Taylor discovers something. That nagging, bothersome voice she was so happy to lose, she starts to miss it. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家伊森·克罗斯是《杂音》一书的作者。他研究了我们脑海中听到的声音所扮演的不同角色。严苛的法官、充满恐惧的预言家、不断重复的反刍者。从这一研究领域产生的一个谜题是：如果我们的内心声音始终是焦虑的源头或抑郁的驱动力，为什么我们脑海中还要有内心声音呢？
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Ethan Cross is the author of the book, Chatter. He has studied the different roles of the voices we hear inside our heads. The harsh judge, the fearful prognosticator, the repetitive ruminator. One of the puzzles that arises from this area of research is this. If our inner voice is consistently a source of anxiety or a driver of depression, why do we have an inner voice at all?
经过数千年的自然选择，难道不应该找到一种方法来消除这种会带来如此多伤害的东西吗？伊森，你曾将内省称为人类心灵的伟大谜题。它自相矛盾的地方在哪里？嗯，它自相矛盾的地方在于，一方面，内省的能力是一个非凡的工具，
Shouldn't natural selection have found a way over thousands of years to remove something that causes so much harm? Ethan, you've called introspection the great puzzle of the human mind. What is paradoxical about it? Well, what's paradoxical about it is that on the one hand, the ability to introspect is a remarkable tool
它是创新的源泉。它是一个让我们能够解决问题的工具。如果你考虑言语内省，特别是许多人所描述的内心声音，这具体指的是我们默默地利用语言来反思我们生活的全过程。这让我们能够做许多许多不同的事情。第一，你的内心声音可以让你将信息在脑海中保持活跃状态非常短暂的时间。
that is a source of innovation. It's a tool that lets us solve problems. If you think about verbal introspection, specifically what many people describe as the inner voice, what that refers to specifically is our ability to silently use language to reflect on our lives. And that lets us do many, many different things. Number one, your inner voice lets you keep information
这是我们所谓的言语工作记忆系统的一部分。所以如果你去杂货店，像我一样，去那里五分钟后，你就忘了你该买什么，于是你停下来对自己说：我为什么非得买奶酪、酸奶、橙子呢？这就是你在使用你的内心声音。你用它来保留信息。但我们也用那个内心声音来做其他事情，比如在做新的演讲之前进行模拟和规划。我会在我的社区散步，
active in your head for very short periods of time. It's part of what we call our verbal working memory system. So if you go to the grocery store and like me, five minutes after you get there, you forget what you were supposed to buy and you pause and you think to yourself, why was I supposed to get cheese, yogurt, oranges? That's you using your inner voice. You're using it to retain information. But we also use that inner voice to do other things like simulate and plan before giving a new presentation. I will go for a walk around my neighborhood
在脑海中过一遍我要说的话，通常是一字不差。我们还用我们的内心声音来控制自己。今天早上我在锻炼，这是一次艰苦的锻炼，我 literalmente在给自己加油鼓劲。“加油，你能行的，再做七次重复动作，然后你就可以休息了。”然后我开始倒计时，七、六、五。
and I'll go through what I'm gonna say, often word for word in my mind. We also use our inner voice to control ourselves. This morning I was exercising, it was a hard workout, I was literally coaching myself along. Come on, you got this, seven more reps, then you get a break. And then I counted down, seven, six, five.
所以我们可以利用那个内心声音来充当教练。最后，我们利用内心声音来讲述故事、创造叙事，帮助我们理解在这个古怪世界中的经历。这些帮助我们理解我们在这一古怪世界中经历的叙事，赋予了我们“我是谁”这一概念以形态。我认为内心声音，更广泛地说，内省，就像是人类心灵的一把瑞士军刀，让我们能够做许多许多不同的事情。
So we can use that inner voice to be a coach. And then finally, we use our inner voice to tell stories, to create narratives that help us understand our experiences in this wacky world. And those narratives that help us understand our experiences in this wacky world and those narratives that we create, they give shape to our sense of who we are. I think of the inner voice and more broadly introspection as a kind of Swiss army knife of the human mind that lets us do many, many different things.
伊森，我在想内心声音赋予我们的另一个特征。当我们做错了某事时，你知道的，我们经常严厉自责、对我们自己感到愤怒、质疑自己、体验到羞耻、体验到懊悔，显然经历这些事情并不有趣，但当然，如果我们想象一个没有经历过这些的世界，一个我们做错了事、却不对发生的事情进行反思的世界，我们可能会完全倾向于一遍又一遍地犯同样的错误。经历负面情绪和消极情绪，
I'm thinking about one other feature that the inner voice gives us, Ethan. When we do something that's wrong, you know, we often castigate ourselves, we are mad at ourselves, we second-guess ourselves, we experience shame, we experience remorse, and obviously it's not fun to go through those things, but of course, if we imagine a world where we didn't go through them, where we did something wrong, where we didn't reflect back on what happened, we might be entirely prone to make the same mistakes over and over again. Experiencing negativity and negative emotions
并不是我们想要迴避的事情。许多科学家（包括我在内）认为，在适当的剂量下体验消极情绪是有功能的。我们进化出了体验羞耻、遗憾、愤怒、悲伤的能力，你可以填上你最喜欢的负面情绪，这是有原因的。它们让我们做好准备去应对我们正在处理的那种局面。
isn't something that we want to shy away from. Many scientists, myself included, believe that negative emotions are functional when experienced in the right dosage. We evolve the capacity to experience shame, regret, anger, sadness, you fill in your favorite negative emotion for a reason. They prepare us for dealing with that situation
它们通常充当一种信号，在说：嘿，你需要专注于此，这样你就不会再次重复这个错误。所以我们不想摆脱消极情绪。我们真正想要弄清楚的是，如何防止这些微小的消极情绪峰值演变成杂音。所以在节目的前半部分，我们探讨了神经科学家
that we're managing. And they often serve as cues to say, hey, you need to focus here so you don't repeat this mistake again. So we don't wanna rid ourselves of negativity. What we do want to figure out is how to prevent those small spikes of negative emotions from morphing into chatter. So earlier in the episode, we explored the story of the neuroscientist
吉尔·博尔特·泰勒的故事。她遭遇了一场中风，导致她无法进行内省。起初，她对那个烦人的内心声音的消失表示欢迎。但伊森，请为我们讲完这个故事。吉尔·博尔特·泰勒因失去内心声音而感受到的解脱，那种感觉是长久的吗？最终发生的情况是，随着时间的推移，当她所有的杂音都消失时，她最初感受到的极乐感
Jill Bolte-Taylor. She suffered a stroke that left her unable to engage in introspection. And at first she welcomed the absence of her bothersome inner voice. But Ethan finished the story for us. Did the relief that Jill Boltey Taylor felt at losing her inner voice, was that long lasting? What ended up happening was the euphoria that she initially felt when all of her chatter went away,
演变成了一种功能失调的状态。因为尽管她不再担忧和反刍，但她同时也失去了做基本事情的能力，比如无法在脑海中保持信息的活跃度，对吧？内心声音是你工作记忆系统的一部分。她失去了组织思维、理解她世界中发生的事情的能力。而她从这段经历中汲取的教训是，
that morphed into a state of dysfunction as time went on. Because although she stopped worrying and ruminating, she also stopped being able to do basic things like keep information active in our head, right? The inner voice is part of your working memory system. She lost that ability to organize her thinking, to make sense of what was happening in her world. And the lesson that she learned from going through this
随着时间的推移，这种情况演变成了一种功能失调的状态。因为尽管她不再担忧和反刍，但她同时也失去了做基本事情的能力，比如无法让信息在头脑中保持活跃，对吧？内心的声音是你工作记忆系统的一部分。她失去了组织思维、理解她世界中正在发生的事情的能力。她从这段经历中得到的教训是
stroke was that the goal for her was no longer to identify ways of silencing her inner voice, of getting rid of it. Instead, the goal became to learn how to manage that inner voice more effectively. So I want to take you back to a story that you told me at the start of this episode, and I want to have you tell me how you in some ways managed to control the chatter that was unfolding inside your head. This was after you went on TV and you received a threatening letter. You were terrified. You started pacing about your house at night with a baseball bat patrolling your house. At one point Ethan, you sat down at your computer and began to search for ways that you could protect yourself. What were you hoping to find
对她而言，目标不再是寻找方法来压制自己内心的声音、摆脱它。相反，目标变成了学习如何更有效地管理这个内心的声音。所以我想带大家回到你在这集节目开始时讲过的一个故事，我想让你讲讲，在某种程度上你是如何控制脑海中不断涌现的杂念的。当时你上了电视，然后收到了一封威胁信。你吓坏了。你开始在夜里拿着棒球棒在家里踱步巡逻。伊桑，有一刻你坐在电脑前，开始搜索如何保护自己。你当时希望找到什么
with your Google search and what happened subsequently? Look, anyone who's experienced chatter knows that the rabbit hole, when you're really in it, can take you down it quite deep and I was very deep down the rabbit hole. And at the very worst of it, I sat down at my laptop and I had the thought, why don't I search for a bodyguard that's specialized in protecting academics? And I didn't actually hit enter on the search. I did type it, but then I thought to myself first, what if someone sees you type this? They'll think you've lost it.
通过你的谷歌搜索，后来发生了什么？听着，任何经历过内心杂念的人都知道，当你真正陷入其中时，那个兔子洞可以带你陷得很深，而我当时就陷在这个兔子洞的很深处。在最糟糕的时候，我坐在笔记本电脑前，心里闪过一个念头：我为什么不找一个专门保护学者的保镖呢？我其实并没有在搜索栏按下回车键。我确实把字打上去了，但我随后转念一想：如果有人看到你打出这些字会怎么样？他们会觉得你疯了。
And then I actually said, I said to myself, what are you doing? Get your act together. And I started talking to myself like I was talking to someone else. And it instantly snapped me out of that very narrow view of my situation that was filled with thoughts about threat and oh my God, what if this happens? And it was more, it was a broader view that I adopted.
然后我真的对自己说，我说：“你在干什么？振作点。”我开始对自己说话，就像在和另一个人说话一样。这瞬间把我从那种对局势的狭隘视角中拉了出来，那种视角充斥着对威胁的想法以及“天哪，如果发生这种事怎么办？”的想法。我采纳的是一种更广阔的视角。
Well, look, I'm not the first person to experience this situation. The police told me that other folks get letters on occasion. They usually blow over. This will too. It's not doing any good to not sleep. So why don't you go upstairs and stop the stuff? And that's exactly what I did. And interestingly enough, if you think back to that letter by Fred Rogers that I read before, he did something very similar.
好吧，听着，我并不是第一个经历这种状况的人。警察告诉我，其他人偶尔也会收到信。这些通常都会过去的。这封信也会过去的。不睡觉一点好处都没有。所以你为什么不楼上睡觉，别想这些了？我就是这么做的。有趣的是，如果你回想一下我之前读过的弗雷德·罗杰斯的信，他做过非常类似的事情。
He used his own name. It was almost as though in both of our circumstances, we were thrust into this other advisory mode. It was like we were giving advice to a good friend. And we then went on to do research on this tool we call a distance Self-Talk. And what it involves doing is trying to coach yourself through your chatter, using your own name or the second person pronoun, you.
他用了自己的名字。在我们的这两种情况下，几乎就像是我们被推入了另一种顾问模式。就像我们在给一位好朋友提建议一样。然后我们继续对这种被称为“距离化自我对话”的工具进行研究。它包含的做法是，试着引导自己穿过内心杂念，使用你自己的名字或第二人称代词“你”。
And it turns out this is a useful tool for helping people gain distance from what they're going through in ways that can be quite useful. So I want you to talk a little bit about that research because in some ways beyond the fact that talking to yourself as if you were outside yourself helped you, you actually have data to show that in fact this technique is effective. You published a study where you asked volunteers to think about personal events that they were worried about and then ask them to think about those events either in the first person or using a different pronoun.
事实证明，这是一个很有用的工具，能帮助人们与他们正在经历的事情保持距离，其效果相当显著。所以我想请你多谈谈那项研究，因为在某种程度上，除了像对待局外人一样对自己说话对你有帮助之外，你实际上有数据表明，这种技巧确实是有效的。你发表了一项研究，要求志愿者思考他们担心的个人事件，然后要求他们用第一人称或使用不同的代词来思考这些事件。
Tell me how you ran that study and how it unfolded. Well, what we did in that study is we had people first tell us about experiences from their past that people might ruminate about, and in another study it dealt with future worries and concerns. And then during the study, we would have people reflect on those experiences.
告诉我你是如何进行这项研究的，以及它是如何展开的。嗯，我们在那项研究中做的是，首先让人们告诉我们他们过去的经历，这些经历可能会让人反刍，而在另一项研究中，它处理的是未来的担忧和焦虑。然后在研究过程中，我们会让人们反思这些经历。
We'd have them think about them and then try to really work through their deepest thoughts and feelings surrounding those events. Half of the time we had them try to work through their feelings as we normally do in the first person. So why did I feel this way? What was going on?
我们会让他们思考这些经历，然后努力真正理清围绕这些事件的最深层的想法和感受。有一半的时间，我们让他们像平常一样用第一人称来理清自己的感受。所以，“我为什么会有这种感觉？到底发生了什么？”
In the other half of the time, though we'd have them use their own name and the second person pronoun you. So Ethan, why did you feel this way? What was going on? And what we found was across both studies, people consistently felt less upset when they use what we call distant self-talk,
不过，在另一半时间里，我们会让他们使用自己的名字和第二人称代词“你”。所以，“伊桑，你为什么会有这种感觉？到底发生了什么？”我们发现，在两项研究中，当人们使用我们所说的“距离化自我对话”时，他们感到的沮丧情绪明显减少了，
when they use their name and the second person pronoun you to try to work through and make sense of what they were going through. What this helps us do is it helps us step back and think about our circumstances more similar to how we would think about something that's happening to another person. And when we do that, we have the enhanced ability
当他们使用自己的名字和第二人称代词“你”来努力理清和理解他们正在经历的事情时。这帮我们做到的，是让我们退后一步，更类似于我们思考发生在别人身上的事情那样来思考我们的处境。当我们这样做时，我们便增强了这样一种能力：
to be more objective and deliberate when we think about our problems. So besides using our names or second person pronouns when talking to ourselves, it turns out there are also other ways of creating psychological distance from our problems. And you found many of these techniques to be beneficial. One of these techniques involves visualization, changing the way we see things in our mind's
在思考我们的问题时，能够更加客观和审慎。因此，除了在对自己说话时使用我们的名字或第二人称代词外，事实证明，还有其他方法可以与我们的问题产生心理距离。你发现其中的许多技巧都很有益。其中一种技巧涉及可视化，即改变我们在心眼中看待事物的方式。
eye. Can you tell me about the work that you and your colleagues have done to test the idea of adopting what's called a fly-on-the-wall perspective on our own problems? Yeah. So when we think about negative experiences or when we anticipate future ones as well, we often have mental imagery surrounding it. And research has shown that we can think
你能讲讲你和你的同事为了验证所谓对我们自己的问题采取“墙上飞蝇”视角这一理念而做过的工作吗？好的。所以，当我们思考消极经历，或者当我们预期未来的消极经历时，我们周围往往伴随着心理意象。研究表明，我们可以思考
about different experiences in our lives from different perspectives. So you can conjure up a mental snapshot of a past event and actually replay it happening in your own mind from a first person perspective. Or you can also think about that same experience, but from a third person perspective, like a fly on the wall peering down on the scene.
我们生活中的不同经历，可以从不同的视角出发。因此，你可以唤起对过去事件的心理快照，并在自己的脑海中实际重放它的发生，这是一种第一人称视角。或者你也可以思考同样的经历，但从第三人称视角出发，就像一只墙上的飞蝇向下俯瞰这个场景一样。
Research has shown that when people adopt a third person or a fly on the wall perspective, that tends to be linked with lower levels of emotionality. And that's true for both positive and negative experiences. In one set of studies, we found that when participants were provoked, when an experimenter in the lab acted in a very rude and insulting way to them,
研究表明，当人们采用第三人称或“墙上飞蝇”的视角时，这往往与较低水平的情绪化联系在一起。对于积极和消极的经历来说都是如此。在一系列研究中，我们发现，当参与者受到挑衅时——当实验室里的实验员以非常粗鲁和侮辱性的方式对待他们时，
if we ask people to reflect on the provocation from a distance, they were much less likely to be aggressive towards that experimenter when given the opportunity than people who were directed to just reflect on the experience as they normally would in the first person. And so more broadly, what I think this speaks to is the fact that, look, it's very easy
如果我们让人们从远处反思这种挑衅，与那些被指示像平常一样用第一人称反思这种经历的人相比，当有机会时，他们对那个实验员表现出攻击性的可能性要小得多。因此，更广泛地说，我认为这说明了一个事实，那就是，看吧，
for us to become consumed with negativity. And when we're consumed with that negativity, we often say things and do things that we would never dream of doing if the emotional amplitude was just a little bit lower. And that's what we see happening with many of these different kinds of distancing techniques. It turns down the temperature just a little bit. It doesn't, I should, and I think this is an important point to convey. When people distance in our studies,
我们非常容易被负面情绪吞噬。当我们被这种负面情绪吞噬时，我们常常会说出一些话，做出一些事，如果当时情绪的振幅哪怕只是稍微低一点，我们都做梦也想不到自己会这样做。这就是我们在许多这些不同类型的距离化技巧中看到的情况。它把温度稍微调低了一点。它并没有——我应该说，我认为这是一个需要传达的重要观点。当人们在我们的研究中保持距离时，
we don't take a negative experience and turn it into a joyfully, blissfully positive event. When I coach myself, you know, Ethan, what are you doing bodyguards for academics? It was still a negative situation I was dealing with, but the intensity of it was diminished to a point where I could think about it more objectively and deliberately.
我们并没有把一段消极经历变成一个快乐的、幸福的积极事件。当我指导自己时，你知道，“伊桑，你给学者找什么保镖？”这仍然是我当时在处理的一个消极情况，但它的强度已经减弱到了我可以更客观、更审慎地思考它的程度。
And that can be really useful. And often the difference between being mired in chatter on the one hand and working through a negative experience adaptively on the other. So we've seen how creating a little distance using language can be effective and creating a little distance using, you know, spatial imagination can be effective. It turns out there's a third way we can also achieve some distance from our own problems. Can you talk about the idea of temporal distance, Ethan? Yeah, I love this distancing tactic.
这真的非常有用。它往往是一方面陷入内心杂念，与另一方面适应性地度过一段消极经历之间的区别。所以我们已经看到，利用语言创造一点距离是如何奏效的，利用——你知道的，空间想象力创造一点距离是如何奏效的。事实证明，还有第三种方法，我们也可以与自己的问题保持一定的距离。伊桑，你能谈谈“时间距离”这个概念吗？是的，我很喜欢这种距离化策略。
It's one that Aslam Aduk and one of her colleagues discovered a few years ago. What it involves doing is remarkably simple and effective. So take your latest worry, rather than think about how awful the circumstance is right now, think about how you're going to feel sometime down the road in the future. What that does, what engaging in that form of what we often call mental time travel does for us, is it makes it clear that whatever we're dealing with, as awful as it is, it will eventually
这是阿斯兰·阿杜克（Aslam Aduk）和她的同事在几年前发现的一种策略。它包含的做法非常简单且有效。所以，拿你最近的担忧来说，与其去想现在的环境有多么糟糕，不如想想你在未来某个时候会有什么感受。这样做——采用我们通常所说的“心理时间旅行”的那种形式对我们所做的是，它让我们清楚地认识到，无论我们正在处理什么，不管它有多糟糕，它最终都会
pass and that gives us hope that can be a very powerful antidote to a negative mind that is overwhelmed with chatter. Ethan and other researchers have also found it helps to give new labels to our emotions. When a negative voice inside you warns of all the bad things that could happen and you feel yourself getting anxious, relabel that anxiety. Another tool that can help people involves changing the way we interpret
过去，这给了我们希望，这对于一个被内心杂念压垮的负面大脑来说，可能是一剂非常强效的解药。伊桑和其他研究人员还发现，为我们的情绪赋予新的标签也有所帮助。当内心的负面声音警告你所有可能发生的坏事，而你感到自己变得焦虑时，给这种焦虑重新贴上标签。另一个能帮助人们的工具涉及改变我们解释事物的方式
what we're going through, shifting from thinking about our circumstances as a threat to thinking about it as a challenge. And the way this works is as follows. When people are experiencing stress, they often ask themselves, and this often happens subconsciously, two kinds of questions.
我们所经历的事情，从将我们的处境视为“威胁”转变为将其视为“挑战”。其运作方式如下。当人们经历压力时，他们经常会问自己（这通常是在潜意识中发生的）两类问题：
What's required of me in this situation? And what resources do I possess to manage it? If you answer those questions, if, you know, okay, there's a lot that's being asked of me and no way I can deal with this, that elicits a threat appraisal, which predicts all sorts of bad stuff,
这种情境对我的要求是什么？我拥有什么资源来应对它？如果你回答了这些问题，如果你知道，“好吧，有很多要求压在我身上，我根本无法应付”，这就会引发威胁评估，进而预示着各种各样糟糕的事情，
poor performance, poor subjective feelings, poor health. And so that's another switch, another lever you can pull to shift how you're functioning in a particular situation. Go from threat to challenge. We've looked at several techniques that individuals can practice, but it's striking of course that, long before you had psychological science come up
表现不佳、主观感觉糟糕、健康状况不佳。所以这是另一个开关，你可以拉动另一个杠杆来改变你在特定情境下的运作方式。从威胁转向挑战。我们已经研究了个人可以练习的几种技术，但引人注目的是，早在心理科学提出解决内心杂念问题的方案之前很久，
with solutions to the problem of chatter, societies have been grappling with ways to help people deal with stressors and out-of-control anxiety. You cited a remarkable study looking at a technique practiced by Israeli women living in war zones. What did the women do to bring their anxieties and that chatter under control? Well, they activated an ancient chatter fighting tool, which was they prayed ritualistically and praying for them was associated with reductions in anxiety. You look at cultures around the world, think about the death of a loved one, right?
社会就一直在寻找各种方法来帮助人们应对压力源和失控的焦虑。你引用了一项引人注目的研究，观察了生活在战区的以色列女性所采用的一种技术。这些女性做了什么来控制她们的焦虑和内心杂念？嗯，她们激活了一种古老的对抗内心杂念的工具，那就是她们进行仪式化的祈祷，对她们来说，祈祷与焦虑的减少息息相关。你看看世界各地的文化，想想亲人的离去，对吧？
Lots of different religions prescribe very, very different kinds of rituals for engaging with that kind of chatter-provoking event. And research shows that engaging in a ritual can actually be helpful for modulating our chatter. One thing to keep in mind is, when we're experiencing chatter, we often feel like we don't have control over the thoughts and feelings that are streaming through our head.
许多不同的宗教为应对那种会引发内心杂念的事件，规定了非常、非常不同种类的仪式。研究表明，参与仪式实际上对调节我们的内心杂念很有帮助。需要记住的一件事是，当我们经历内心杂念时，我们常常觉得无法控制流经我们脑海的思想和感觉。
And one of the reasons we think rituals are helpful is because a ritual is under your control. It's a rigid sequence of behaviors that you perform the same way every time. That's something that you have agency over. And that's a way of compensating for the lack of control we often feel when we're struggling with chatter. for the lack of control we often feel when we're struggling with chatter. Another way that they can aid us is they're often attentionally demanding, which is to say rituals are often complicated and to execute them we have to focus on the individual parts of performing those rituals and that can take our attention away momentarily from the chatter we're experiencing and give us a bit of distraction. And so that's another pathway through which rituals can help.
我们认为仪式有帮助的原因之一，是因为仪式是在你的掌控之下的。它是一系列你每次都以相同方式执行的严格行为。这是你拥有自主权的事情。这是对我们在与内心杂念作斗争时常常感到的缺乏控制力的一种补偿。对于我们在与内心杂念作斗争时常常感到的缺乏控制力的一种补偿。它们能给予我们的另一种帮助是，它们通常对注意力有很高的要求，也就是说，仪式往往很复杂，为了执行它们，我们必须专注于执行这些仪式的各个部分，这可以暂时将我们的注意力从我们正在经历的内心杂念中转移开，给我们一点分心的空间。所以这是仪式可以提供帮助的另一条途径。
And of course, we see these rituals not just in the context of religion. We see this in sports all the time. You tell the story of the Australian swimmer Stephanie Rice. Before every race, she swings her arms eight times Presses her goggles four times touches her cap four times. I mean it does sound religious, but clearly it's just about sports performance Yeah, so there's research which has shown that you can give people arbitrary rituals to engage in you know clap their hands three times spin around in their seat twice and then tap their head. And engaging in those kinds of non-religious rituals
当然，我们不仅在宗教背景下看到这些仪式。我们在体育运动中随时都能看到这一点。你讲述了澳大利亚游泳运动员斯蒂芬妮·赖斯（Stephanie Rice）的故事。在每次比赛前，她都会挥舞手臂八次，按压泳镜四次，触摸泳帽四次。我的意思是这听起来确实很宗教化，但很显然这纯粹是为了体育表现。是的，所以有研究表明，你可以给人们任意的仪式让他们参与，你知道，拍手三次，在座位上转两圈，然后拍拍头。参与那些非宗教仪式
can be beneficial as well. Probably the most famous athlete who's known for doing rituals is Rafael Nadal. Several years ago, a journalist asked Nadal, what's the hardest thing you struggle with on the tennis court? And his answer surprised a lot of people because he didn't say the hardest thing I do
也可能是有益的。可能最出名以喜欢做仪式而闻名的运动员是拉斐尔·纳达尔。几年前，一名记者问纳达尔：“在网球场上，你与之挣扎的最难的事情是什么？”他的回答让很多人感到惊讶，因为他没有说最难的事情
is making sure I keep my serve in check or return my opponent's backhand. And his answer surprised a lot of people because he didn't say the hardest thing I do is, you know, making sure I keep my serve in check or return my opponent's backhand. Instead he says, the hardest thing I struggle with is to battle the voice inside my head. The hardest thing he struggles with is his chatter on the court. And if you watch Nadal play,
是确保我控制好发球或回击对手的反手。他的回答让很多人感到惊讶，因为他没有说最难的事情是，你知道，确保我控制好发球或回击对手的反手。相反，他说：“我与之挣扎的最难的事情，是与我脑海中的声音作斗争。”他在球场上面对的最难的事情是他的内心杂念。如果你看纳达尔比赛，
you will see his solution for managing that chatter. He engages in elaborate rituals from the time he enters the court to before every single serve. He has specific rituals that he engages in. And when he's been asked, why do you do these wacky rituals? And yet again, Rafael Nadal finds a way. He says, these rituals are a way of ordering my mind,
你会看到他管理这种内心杂念的解决方案。从他进入球场到每一次发球之前，他都会进行精心准备的仪式。他有特定的仪式要执行。当被问到“你为什么要做这些古怪的仪式？”时，拉斐尔·纳达尔再次找到了解决办法。他说，这些仪式是整理我思维的一种方式，
providing the order I seek in a match. I understand that you have some rituals of your own to combat your inner chatter before giving a big speech. I do. I will pound a fist into my hand two or three times. I will give myself a little mini, very brief distant self-talk pap-talk. You know, come on man, you've got this. And if it's a really, really high-stakes event, I've been known to do a few push-ups right before showtime as well.
为我在比赛中提供我所寻求的秩序。我听说你在发表大型演讲前也有自己的一些仪式来对抗内心的杂念。是的。我会用拳头砸手两到三次。我会给自己做一个小型的、非常短暂的“距离化自我对话”式的打气。你知道，“拜托，兄弟，你行的”。如果这是一场风险极高、极高的活动，据我所知，在登台亮相之前，我也会做几个俯卧撑。
We started this conversation by having you tell me about your experience as a young undergrad at Penn who was dealing with setbacks when you first got a college. One of the people you reached out to for help at that time was your dad and it turns out that your dad played a really formative role not just in helping you while you were at Penn, but in some ways helping you think about the whole idea of introspection more generally. I'm wondering if you could tell me a little bit about your dad and the connection between his insights and the work that you've been doing these last several decades. One of the interesting ahas I had was that although I had been
我们这次谈话的开始，是让你讲述你在宾夕法尼亚大学读本科时的经历，当时你刚上大学，正在应对各种挫折。你在那个时候寻求帮助的对象之一是你的父亲，事实证明，你的父亲不仅在你在宾夕法尼亚大学期间对你起到了至关重要的塑造作用，而且在某种程度上，他帮助你更广泛地思考了内省这个整个概念。我想知道你能否跟我讲讲你的父亲，以及他的见解与你这几十年一直在做的工作之间的联系。我顿悟到的有趣事情之一是，尽管我一直在
researching chatter and how to manage it for about 20 years, I've been thinking about it for close to 40. The reason for that is I had an unconventional dad. My dad was someone who on the one hand, loved watching the New York Yankees and driving aggressively on the streets of Brooklyn and chain smoking, Brooklyn bushy mustache kind of guy. But when he wasn't doing all those things, he was, he was reading Eastern philosophy
研究内心杂念以及如何管理它大约有20年，但我思考这个问题已经快40年了。原因是我有一个非传统的父亲。我父亲一方面喜欢看纽约扬基队的比赛，在布鲁克林的街道上狂野驾驶，还抽雪茄，是个布鲁克林式的留着浓密胡须的家伙。但当他不干这些事情的时候，他一直在阅读东方哲学
and the Bhagavad Gita and meditating. And when he wasn't doing those things, he was talking to me as a three year old about what he was learning about. He wasn't a college grad or, you know, this wasn't, he wasn't a professor, by the way, it's just a hobby that he had. He was fascinated by the mind and our ability to manage it. And the message that he conveyed to me from the time I was a little kid was,
和《薄伽梵歌》，并且在冥想。而当他不做这些事情的时候，他会和一个三岁的孩子——也就是我——谈论他正在学习的的东西。他不是大学毕业生，你知道，这并不是——他不是什么教授，顺便说一句，这只是他的一个爱好。他对外在的心智以及我们管理心智的能力着迷。他从小就向我传达的信息是，
whenever something is going wrong, turn your attention inward and try to work through the situation. The way he said that to me was, he'd give me this corny phrase, go inside, find the kernel of truth, he would say. That was a message that he just conveyed to me over and over from the time I was a little kid.
每当有什么事情出错时，把你的注意力转向内部，试着理清这个状况。他对我说这话的方式是，他会给我这样一个老土的短语：“走进去，找到真理的核心，”他会说。从我还是个小孩子的时候起，这就是他一遍又一遍向我传达的信息。
And it was a tool that I, as a result, relied on throughout my child and adolescence. So I get into an argument or I ask a girl out. They'd say, no, I'd go inside and introspect, try to work through, figure out why this happened, come up with a solution and move on. And then I got to Penn, I experienced some of my own chatter, and then I ended up taking a psychology class
因此，这也是我在整个童年和青春期一直依赖的工具。所以当我跟人吵架，或者我约一个女孩出去被拒绝时，我会走进去进行内省，试着理清头绪，弄清楚为什么会发生这种情况，想出一个解决方案然后继续前进。然后我到了宾夕法尼亚大学，经历了我自己的内心杂念，然后我最终选修了一门心理学课程，
and I learned in that class that lots of people do exactly what my dad had told me to do when they struggle with something and they benefit as a result. This ability to introspect was a remarkable tool. But in some cases that tool failed lots of people as well. And discovering that puzzle, why is it that we have this tool, sometimes it helps, other times it hurts us, that became a passion of mine that I've been trying to solve ever since. Ethan Cross is a psychologist at the University of Michigan.
我在那门课上了解到，当许多人在与某些事情挣扎时，他们会做我父亲告诉我的完全相同的事情，并且因此受益。这种内省的能力是一个非凡的工具。但在某些情况下，这个工具对很多人来说也失效了。发现这个谜题——为什么我们拥有这个工具，有时它有帮助，有时它却伤害了我们——成了一种让我着迷的热情，我此后一直试图解开它。伊桑·克劳斯是密歇根大学的心理学家。
He's the author of the book, Chatter, The Voice in Our Head, Why It Matters, and How to Harness It. Ethan, thank you for talking to me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shankar. It was a pleasure. brain. Thanks so much for having me Shankar. It was a pleasure. If you have follow-up questions for Ethan Cross that you'd be willing to share with members of the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty and please use the subject line, Mental Chatter.
他是《内心杂念：我们头脑中的声音，为什么它重要以及如何驾驭它》（Chatter, The Voice in Our Head, Why It Matters, and How to Harness It）一书的作者。伊桑，谢谢你今天在《隐藏的大脑》节目中与我交谈。非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔。这真是我的荣幸。大脑。非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔。这真是我的荣幸。如果你有后续问题想问伊桑·克劳斯，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请录制一段语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复该电子邮件地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了，请使用主题行：心理杂念。
If you want to write out a question, please be sure to tell us how to pronounce your name. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you're a fan of the show, if you feel we have given you ideas that have been useful in your life, please help us make more episodes like this. The best way to do so is to join our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus, which is
如果你想写下一个问题，请务必告诉我们如何发音你的名字。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒公司（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·伯恩斯（Autumn Burns）、安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你是本节目的粉丝，如果你觉得我们为你提供了对你的生活有用的观点，请帮助我们制作更多这样的剧集。最好的方法是加入我们的播客订阅“隐藏的大脑Plus”（Hidden Brain Plus），它现在
now available across platforms and devices. If you are on an iPhone or iOS device, go to apple.co.uk. Android users can find us at support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, those sites are apple.co.hiddenbrain and support.hiddenbrain.org. We truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
已在各大平台和设备上推出。如果你使用的是iPhone或iOS设备，请访问apple.co.uk。安卓用户可以在support.hiddenbrain.org找到我们。再次说明，这些网址是apple.co.hiddenbrain和support.hiddenbrain.org。我们非常感谢您的支持。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。